je partirai très bientôt pour la
métropole afin de représenter notre île
la martinique à l'élection nationale 10
15 17 nationale 2020 cependant je n'ai
pas forcément d'appréhension parce que
je pense que ça pourrait gâcher la chose
du coup je pars avec l'esprit positif et
surtout je me dis que je devrais donner
le meilleur de moi même afin de ne pas
avoir de regrets ni fille s'y adonnent
d'un très grand soutien familial
non papa maman mes petits frères et
soeurs mes sponsors personnels et
caetera et je suis vraiment très
reconnaissante envers eux et je suis la
marraine de l'association matete qui
luttent justement contre le cancer du
sein mais je défend des causes qui sont
la lutte contre la drépanocytose contre
le cancer contre l'unfp scellement les
troubles dys et l'autize alors
concernant les pathologies mes proches
sont atteintes de ces dernières et je
suis témoin du combat qu'ils sont en
train de mener au quotidien
et concernant le harcèlement et bien
c'est une histoire assez personnelle
puisque j'ai été moi même harcelés
récemment